[Music]  hi everybody i'm lauren zima we're here  at the I go live app lunch event where  Bella Thorne took over the red carpet  and we talked to her about everything  from style to who she might be crushing  on  are you fine solo tonight have a date  I'm fine with my crew I got a whole crew  with me today yeah everybody story but  how you used like are obsessed with dub  Cameron is there any guy that you're  crushing on lately who you would hope to  meet or maybe see out and about no I  but you know you don't want it you guys  I'm sure you'll figure it out soon  enough not Scott just oh can you clear  it up once and for all what what is that  relation I can't hear you really get  into it and I have absolutely nothing to  say we're friends  deal with it people can be friends it's  a thing it actually happens  get over it guys wheeler it's me you're  styling one word for the food  like I said before  [Music]  you